et pour être totalement clair sur ce que
l'on peut faire ou ne peut plus faire à
partir de demain on fait le point sur
les nouvelles règles en vigueur avec
audrey champigny journaliste à tv tours
bonsoir redressement
alors on va commencer très clairement
est ce que on peut aller piquer une tête
à la piscine durant ses vacances
la réponse est non elles sont fermées au
grand public à partir de demain samedi
et ce jusqu'au 5 septembre
une exception cependant elle reste
ouverte pour les mineurs et les sportifs
de haut niveau
en clair votre enfant peut aller se
baigner mais sans accompagnateur par
exemple à joué-lès-tours la piscine
bulle d'eau peut accueillir votre enfant
à partir de 10 ans mais sans vous si
votre adolescence suit des cours de
natation là encore ces cours se
poursuivent en résumé pour les plus de
18 ans la piscine c'est terminé pour les
six prochaines semaines
est-ce que je peux continuer à aller
faire du sport dans les gymnases ou dans
les salles de fitness audrey non plus
les équipements couverts gymnase salle
polyvalente salle de fitness sont
désormais fermés vous pratiquer le yoga
dans la salle des fêtes de votre village
eh bien les cours s'arrêtent
vous faites du badminton dans le gymnase
de votre quartier et bien là non plus ce
n'est plus possible
mais il ya encore des exceptions
toujours pour les mineurs votre enfant
fait du basket par exemple les
entraînements se poursuivent et après
les vacances les scolaires pourront eux
aussi utiliser ces lieux couverts
autre exception elle concerne les
sportifs de haut niveau comme par
exemple les joueurs du tours volley ball
eux aussi peuvent continuer à jouer
alors ce sont les vacances de la
toussaint pour tout ce qui est loisirs
en famille est ce qu'il reste encore des
lieux ouverts que l'on peut fréquenter
eh bien je vais vous prendre deux
exemples car les contours sont encore un
peu flou nous avons appelé deux
structures à tours-nord une salle
d'escaladé accueille les enfants à
partir de 12 ans mais les parents eux ne
peuvent pas grimper et puis autre
exemple à chambray-lès-tours cette fois
dans une salle de trampoline pour le
moment pas de restrictions nous dit on
les adultes peuvent sauter sur les
trampolines peuvent s'amuser
l'idée évidemment c'est de se renseigner
auprès des différents clubs et
associations
alors qu'en est il pour les sports
on joue à l'extérieur alors là
effectivement c'est un petit peu
différent puisque la pratique du sport à
l'extérieur elles ne changent pas que ce
soit du rugby du fou de l'athlétisme
mineurs ou majeurs vous pouvez faire du
sport attention en revanche les
vestiaires ne sont plus accessibles sauf
pour les matches de haut niveau
professionnel
évidemment pour les entraînements et
matches pros et amateurs
les horaires seront décalées pour
respecter l'heure du couvre feu
moi aussi j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma
ou d'aller voir un spectacle audrey
alors tout va être question d'adaptation
si on prend l'exemple des cinémas il
reste ouvert mais suivent le couvre-feu
et s'adapte ça veut dire quoi
et bien par exemple au studio la
dernière séance sera à 18 heures pour
que les gens aient le temps de rentrer à
temps pour 21h pour les salles de
spectacles les concerts théâtre ils
restent ouverts également exemple à
l'opéra de tours rien ne change
concernant la programmation
ce qui change ce sont les horaires à les
spectacles ont lieu plus tôt idem pour
les spectacles en extérieur à loches par
exemple les illuminations de la
collégiale sainte ours sont avancés
d'une demi heure
vous l'avez compris tout va se jouer au
cas par cas aux tourangeaux de se
renseigner la règle qui prime c'est 21h
heures du couvre feu
et puis dernières informations
concernant les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur on reste sur
les mesures en vigueur
ils pourront accueillir 50 % des
étudiants en présentiel
ainsi audrey pour toutes les précisions